I'm doing good too thank you
why don't you go ahead and tell us a
little bit about yourself
sure thank you stupid so hi everyone
this is Prashant sahu so I'm a
blockchain consultant and a trainer and
simply learn and apart from that I'm a
professional script master and a
Microsoft certified trainer and apart
from that I have been having a lot of
experience into this blockchain domain I
started my journey in the year 20 uh 15
precisely if I would say I started with
Bitcoin explored more about Bitcoin and
then later uh I moved into the
blockchain technology because as you may
be aware that behind this technology
there is something called as a Bitcoin
so I started my journey with Bitcoin
trading and then later moved into the
blockchain technology so I have a lot of
experience towards creating an
Enterprise level application this work
closely with the government of Telangana
uh to create and land and Enterprise
blockchain apart from that I've also
represented India in the China
international Big Data Expo 2018 uh like
from the Chinese government I got a call
and I'm also representative of the
government of international
production Council for the government of
Telangana and for the Goa recently I've
also published my patent which is how to
integrate the education certificates
using ipfs and blockchain so yeah Stuart
this is a very short intro about me just
want to showcase yeah thank you stupid
congratulations on your patent thank you
um
so just to give everyone an orientation
to what we're going to be talking about
today
um I'll go through very briefly with uh
the curriculum of the IIT Concord
blockchain program
and then we'll uh
present a sample lesson out of that
curriculum we'll start with just the
fundamentals of blockchain because it's
a new technology a lot of people are not
familiar with it so starting at the
beginning makes sense for this
particular exercise and then after our q
a I'll tell you more about the IIT
conference program itself
so um
Sean you can help me as we go through
this
program curriculum
start with the orientation session which
is
just the session that helps Learners
understand the online platform that
they'll be learning on where to find
their curriculum and classes how to
register for the live virtual classes
where to do their projects and so forth
once they finish that orientation
session they move into that first
introduction module
so that is the orientation to the
technology and its applications is that
correct
yes that's right so here they'll get an
idea about what is this technology what
are its core properties and the very
first application of the blockchain
technology Bitcoin so a very good
orientation would be given with regards
to what exactly is a blockchain and as
well as first application of the
blockchain which is Bitcoin
and then you move into some of the uh
well the first tool to ethereum
and what is ethereum
do exactly
right so after which yes we exactly
enter into ethereum which is one of the
very famous application right now
currently in the market so using this
ethereum generally we will be able to
create our own decentralized application
on top of the blockchain platform so
ethereum gives us that Liberty to go
ahead and do so we will learn about the
basics of ethereum and understand how to
create the smart contracts and deploy
the same on top of the ethereum
blockchain which is the second
application of the blockchain technology
along the way as you're doing these
modules you're doing projects that uh
cover the the material that you're
learning so understanding consensus and
hash which is a fundamental to how the
blockchain gets constructed how you add
blocks to the chain
so moving from that go ahead yeah I was
just saying that's true uh consensus is
all about the nature the very nature of
the blockchain that why it is so unique
in nature is because everything is
distributed in nature so the data gets
distributed across all the nodes and
that is happening because of the
consensus or understanding between all
the nodes in the network so we'll get to
know what is what are the different
types of consensus mechanisms and
protocols as part of understand
consensus and hashing mechanism yeah
just want to add
and then you move into hyper Ledger
which is a
area of uh blockchain that application
that allows you to extend to a lot of
other
practical applications in
business and industry is that correct
yes
fabric is absolutely an Enterprise level
oriented blockchain
so as you rightly sets to it so it will
be all about the Practical aspects like
where we will be creating our own
Enterprise level applications and
hyperledger fabric is also a
permissioned blockchain which will be a
right fit for the Enterprise blockchain
actually
yeah and then uh the next module on
Smart contracts and networks is takes it
even further into the
you know kind of the Practical and
Enterprise domain in terms of things
like self-executing contracts
um one of the areas where
blockchain technology is
expected to make a one of its biggest
impacts yes
absolutely
and then we move into
um
the
other blockchain Platforms in other
areas
um I mean do recorded Iota we're
internet of things and that type of
uh yes extended
blockchain application
absolutely yes these are the other
platforms which we will explore as part
of our program curriculum understanding
what is this R3 quota Internet of Things
application these are the uh two very
good applications which have been
running in the market so we will also be
able to get an insights about that and
as well as what are the other platforms
which are being utilized with regards to
the blockchain technology will also be
discussed
So based on this stepwise uh building of
your skills you get to the point where
you can now
uh look at the applications of
blockchain in the real world and
understand them more thoroughly and how
they were constructed and
approaches that could have been taken
that type of thing
um that is the foundation and lead into
the Capstone project so how does the
Capstone project work
okay yes absolutely so as you rightly
search to it so all these steps which
you could see from bottom to top will
actually give us a very good idea
towards this technology we will be
having a lot of Hands-On practical
aspects where we will be creating a lot
of applications a case studies which are
actually required for this technology so
we will be writing the smart contracts
using solidity programming language we
will be creating the hyperledger fabric
application using Java and then go
language we'll be focusing on
multi-chain so it's a combination of
everything and finally we will be able
to do a Capstone project where we will
take a real case study based on your
understanding whatever we have done
right so you will be creating your own
project with the guidance of the
trainers so that you will be able to go
ahead and showcase that project to the
real world that what exactly you have
developed using the blockchain so it's
more towards the real case studies to it
which we are going to discuss as part of
a Capstone project yeah that's that's
very important because that means that
the end of the program
the the person receiving the certificate
also receives their uh get portfolio of
all the projects they've done including
the Capstone so they have practical
experience now that they can demonstrate
as part of their uh
Career Development job search seeking a
pay rise or a
promotion you have the evidence to back
that up and along the way you can take
the elective master classes from
instructors and faculty that talk about
different topics of blockchain these
all right no additional cost in the
program so those are really valuable so
I'm going to turn this over to you to
talk about uh fundamentals of blockchain
and
basics of
Concepts behind it so
I will log you uh to go ahead and share
your screen
sure yeah I'll be just sharing my screen
and they'll be moving ahead to it okay
once this topics are completed I'll hand
it back to you all right
thank you I'll be here
let me quickly share my screen
okay hope that my screen is visible with
a blank white board yes oh perfect thank
you
okay so I just wanted to give a small
context of what exactly is blockchain uh
like how blockchain is actually
important what are all the things we
have to consider so I'll make it as
precise as possible so that all of you
could get an understanding like what
exactly the stock technology is actually
talking about
so the very first thing as we are
referring about the blockchain
technology so let me just put it up over
here so when I say blockchain technology
why are we talking about this technology
like what is that which is within this
technology which is actually making it
so powerful that everyone is talking
about this technology you see everywhere
the government entities you take the
service based companies or product based
companies everyone is striving to work
towards this technology because there is
some potentiality which is
it's a very broad line if I would say
the security is something like where a
lot of components have been involved so
what I'm talking here specifically is
let me say you in this fourth Industrial
Revolution we all know that data is an
important asset whosoever is going to
protect the data in the current market
they are the rules
okay if you are not in a position to
protect the data then definitely you
will not be in the market for a long
time
so now we are looking a different
Alternatives and possibilities to make
sure that we can be able to protect the
data as much as we can so how how is
this possible what are all the things we
have to consider is something which we
are going to discuss right now as the
fundamentals of the blockchain
technology
so the very first thing as you all have
taken some amount of time and you've
joined this respective webinar so all of
you should first need to understand that
why I have I come here why am I learning
this technology is there any purpose of
this technology which I am gonna
learning right now yes the reason is we
are talking about this blockchain
technology to make sure that we can
protect the data as much as we can this
is the first and foremost thing which we
all should be able to consider the main
aspect of this blockchain technology is
to go ahead and try to provide a
security to the data data can be anytime
okay it may be coming from the health
sector it may come from the finance
sector it may come from I.T sector
whatever sector it may be at the end of
the day it is a data now if you are not
in a position to protect the data then
it may go to the wrong hands and and
then you know if it goes to wrong hands
what will be the consequences so today
in the market why we are talking about
blockchain technology is to ensure that
we are protecting the data as much as we
can using some of the concepts of the
blockchain technology so this is the
core area which all of you should be
able to understand so when we talk about
the blockchain technology the main core
part of this technology is to ensure
that we are protecting the data as much
as we can by providing a layer of
security to our data this is the reason
why we are right now talking about the
blockchain technology as all of you may
be aware data is right now an asset
okay so if you are not in a position to
protect this asset then it may actually
create a lot of problems so that is the
reason why we are all focusing on this
technology and ensuring that how we can
be able to proceed and protect the data
as much as we can
so this is the fundamental thing which
every one of you should first need to
understand before we dig deep and
understand what exactly this technology
is all about
so blockchain technology is in a
position right now to protect the data
okay we are providing security and
transparency to whatever data it may be
that is the reason today there is a lot
of demand for this technology because
data is getting generated enormously and
if we are not in a position to protect
the data then it will become a very
serious issue going forward because if
the data goes to wrong hands the
consequences will really be different
so that is where the blockchain
technology is actually gonna fit and it
is gonna play a very vital role this is
something which we should all first need
to consider with regards to blockchain
technology
now moving little bit further okay
moving little bit further like as we got
to know okay blockchain is all about
protecting the data giving the security
to the data providing the transparency
to the data so now we got a holistic
view at least of what exactly this
technology is all about so let me go one
step further and make every one of you
understand what exactly is making this
technology so strong
that it is able to go ahead and try to
protect the data
so there should be something which is
within the technology which says that I
am able to go ahead and protect the data
so it is actually giving you peace it is
giving you a good amount of sleep
because at the end of the day the
technology says you don't need to worry
okay you just Implement me I'm gonna
take care of whatever the data you want
to preserve within me and that is your
blockchain
so we should know what exactly is there
within this blockchain
so that today we are in a position to
protect the data as much as we can so
now I'll be able to walk you through
those things so before we understand
what are those properties or
characteristics of the technology which
is actually making it so strong to
protect the data so before we enter into
it let me give you a small understanding
of architecture of this technology like
what is a block what is a chain why do
we call it as a blockchain like what is
that which is getting stored within the
blockchain
how do things have been outlined with
the net so we should get some clarity
with regards to it let me bring out that
respective point to all of you that how
the blockchain actually looks like what
is that which is there within this
technology then we will understand the
properties of the blockchain technology
like what it is actually there within
the blockchain so that it is protecting
the data in a very strong manner
okay so what I'm gonna do right now is
let me just put up the architecture in
front of you so that all of you would
get a Clarity that what it is on it
so now
see the term says block right and then
it says chain
actually these are two different words
block and chain which have been clubbed
together because there is a significance
behind it which you are going to get to
know as part of the architecture
so now let me say you one important
thing let me consider a block
okay so let me consider a block over
here now this is my block so inside my
blog
what is that I'm going to have
simply I would say you are going to have
your data
now that data can be any data it may be
your education certificate
it may be a land record
it may be the patient record whatever
domain you have been working with you
can be able to take that corresponding
data
and try to add the same into the block
so now the blocks are gonna store
something called as data within it so
you can be able to go ahead and store
whatever data you want either it may be
a crypto transactions which you do like
if you are transferring some amount of
Bitcoins or if you are transferring some
amount of ethers or it may be a patient
record or your education certificate it
may be any type of data which you can be
able to take it and add it within your
block the very first thing is your data
which is present inside a block
the second component which is present
within the block is which we call it as
here hash
okay what is a hash
to talk about hash okay let me make the
concept very simple
now if I ask you a question
how do you identify as a unique person
when compared to others many people will
have different different approaches
saying that you have your national
identity as a different some people say
my DNA is different some may say my Iris
scanner is different some say my
fingerprint is unique when compared to
others I agree with all of them
but what I would suggest here is let's
take a fingerprint to make the concept
very simple
like how we have a fingerprint as a
unique
character for us like let me say my
fingerprint is unique and at the same
time every one of you may be having your
own corresponding fingerprints which is
unique actually when compared to others
so here
a block will also have its own
fingerprint
and that is called as your hash
so hash here means it is a unique
identity okay whatever hash is present
the hash is actually the unique identity
for a respective block
so whenever you see a block every block
will have its own unique identity which
we call it as a hash
so hash here is nothing but it is a
unique identity for a corresponding
block so you can correlate this with
your fingerprint how you have your
fingerprint as a unique identity for
yourself in the same way every block
will have its own fingerprint or a own
unique identity which we generally call
it as a hash
okay then the third important component
of the block that is something called as
previous hash
okay we call it as the previous hash now
this previous hash I will be able to
talk about this little later let's just
give around two to three minutes of time
to understand what is previous hash so
before this I want to just elaborate
this picture little bit what I'm gonna
do right now here is we are talking
about the particular block
so let me say if there are sequence of
blocks okay let me say I'm just adding
some sequence of blocks just to make the
concept much easier to all of you okay
so now if you see there are around five
blocks which are being present right it
is block number one block number two
three four and five I just want to
number it so now
technically if you just see this right
everyone can say me what are these if I
ask you you will definitely be able to
say me that these are your block numbers
but technically we don't call this as a
block number
generally there is a term being defined
for this and that is nothing but it is
called as your block height
so one two three four five whatever you
are able to see the numbers over here
generally the person who is new to this
technology they may feel that this is a
block number which I totally agree but
gradually when we move forward and
understand the concepts appropriately
this shouldn't be called as a block
number indeed it should be called as
something called as your block height
okay so when I say block height block
height is nothing but it is your block
number we are referring technically it
has the block height
okay so now
till now if you see every block is going
to have what the first component is data
data can be any data which you want to
store which I already have explained in
the block number three and then what it
is going to have the block number one is
also going to have its own hash
hash means it is a unique identity of
this block like how we have a
fingerprint same happens for the block
number two they have their own data and
hash again three four five every block
like this there are millions of blocks
which are being created in the next
millions of blocks and every block is
going to have the components whatever we
discussed right now that is every block
is going to have their own data every
block is going to have its own identity
which is a hash and then they are also
going to have something called as a
previous hash which we didn't discuss
yet so now it's time to discuss about
what exactly is a previous hash also
okay so till now if you see all of these
are blocks
right
but why do we call it as a chain then if
it would have been called as a block
technology it would have been nice
because everything is present in the
block there would be some sense if we
would have called this as the block
technology
but why did this chain got added to the
term called as block and it finally
became blockchain because if you take a
normal change just take a normal chain
and
what is the significance of a normal
chain every link is interlinked if you
take a normal chain right every link
whatever is available it gets internally
so now if you break the chain it is very
difficult let me say you have broken the
chain successfully and then you will get
to know where the link has been broken
actually
that will give you the clear picture
that where the link has been broken and
you'll get to know that what has
happened behind this like who is
actually done this and from which link
it has actually got hampered same
concept same mechanism can also be used
over here when we talk about the chain
every block here
let me say in my case there are five
blocks which I am trying to show to all
of you so all these five blocks I can be
able to link them in the form of a links
which are being present in a chain so
now block one two three all of these I
am going to link it
like this in the world there are
millions of blocks which are interlinked
among themselves
can you say me how so now I am going to
show you that
let me say you let us start with the
first block
the first block is having its own
corresponding data and it also has its
own hash which is the fingerprint of the
first block
now first block hash
will become second blocks previous hash
okay so let me say the block 1 has a
hash of let us say one two three
now this one two three here will become
the previous hash of the block number
two and again block number two is going
to have its own hash
that is its identity
now let me say block number two is
having a hash of four five six
now block 2 hash which is four five six
will become third block previous sash
okay that is four five six will be
present here and then again third block
is going to have its own hash let me say
that is 789 now this chain will keep on
going like this now fourth block when
you go again fourth block is going to
have its own data it is also going to
have its own hash
and whereas fourth blocks previous hash
will be what third block cache which is
456 is there right that will become the
fourth Block's previous hash so it will
become year four five six in this way if
You observe all the blocks which are
being there in the network they are all
interlinked all of them are here been
interlinked in the form of the previous
hash so they are all Linked In the
backward direction if you are aware of
the concept of linked list it is more or
less same
okay these are all been interlinked in
such a way so that if anybody wants to
come and tamper any of the block so you
are not giving them only one block to
Tamper but we are giving them that if
you want to go and break anything not
only this corresponding block you have
to break everything which is connected
to it so you are making the attacker's
life difficult for example if a attacker
comes and tries to hamper the third
block so you are not saying that it's
okay you come and try to hamper the
third block that's it no you are saying
if you want to attack third block you
can do that but apart from that you also
need to attack the fourth block fifth
block like this whatever the sets of
blocks are there you have to go ahead
and break all of them then only you can
become a successful attacker so we are
making the attacker life here very
difficult saying that not the single
block but you have to go and break all
the links which are interlinked in the
form of the previous hash all throughout
the blocks
so that is the reason we call this as
the Block Chain the reason being here is
every block in this case is been
interlinked with the help of the
previous hash so simply to be said first
block has its hash this hash will become
the second Block's previous hash second
block will also have its own
corresponding hash
then second blocks hash will become the
third block previous hash
then third block will also have its own
hash
again third block hash will become the
fourth Block's previous hash and fourth
block will have its own hash
block hash will become the fifth block
previous hash and fifth block will again
have its own hash in this way every
block in the network is said to be
interlinked in the form of the chain
mechanism this is what we call it as the
blockchain
okay this is how every block is said to
be interlinked and they are all been
designed appropriately
now the very first block inside the
blockchain is called as the Genesis
block
okay the first block inside the
blockchain is called as your Genesis
block the name of the first block inside
the blockchain network is actually
called as your Genesis block
whereas rest of the blocks they are not
having any such name as Genesis only the
first block within the blockchain
network is actually called as your
Genesis plot whereas the corresponding
blocks they have their own block height
so if you see here in the block number
one
what will be the previous hash of my
block one
if you closely observe this the previous
hash of my first block will be zero
what is the reason behind it because
this is my first block right there are
no blocks before it or there are no
blocks prior to it so as there are no
blocks prior to it so automatically you
can actually be able to see that as
there are no blogs prior to it right so
previous hash by default will be zero so
you are not going to have any other
components been added over here and this
is only for the first block because as
you know this is the first block and as
there are no blocks prior to it so
obviously the previous hash becomes 0 in
this case so this is how the entire
architecture of the technology looks
like
this is something which all of you
should be having at least a small
overview or an idea that how this
blockchain is architected and how it is
been designed so that we all can be able
to leverage the benefit of it so in
every block what is that we are going to
have the data
okay and every block is interlinked with
the help of the previous hash
and every block has its unique identity
which is its hash which you can
correlate it with your fingerprint and
every block has its own block number
okay we don't call it as a block number
if you remember I said technically we
call it as the block height okay it
should be referred as the block height
that's it this these are certain core
topics which you should be first aware
before you go ahead and dig deep into
this technology
okay now
there is still a pending question which
we discussed at the start
what is that which is actually making
this technology so strong safe and
secure
what are certain components which are
being available within this technology
you can call it as a properties of the
technology using units so that you can
be able to achieve that capability to go
ahead and mine yourself
and I think part of that question also
is how do you get authorization within
the the structure of a given blockchain
to be one of the miners
that's what like if you want to become a
minor so you have to first achieve the
computation power second you have to
become a full node full node here means
you will have such a system capability
you need to have a good storage of your
system where you can be able to handle
all the blockchain within your system
itself so you need to become a full node
you need to have the computation problem
if these two criteria is met you can be
able to go and play with your block that
means play in the sense you can create
your own blocks
and
we have a question from someone from a
mechanical background
who wants to Pivot into blockchain
technology
now would you recommend they proceed
that
yes see uh this technology is actually
not within only the it domain or
software domain okay this technology is
applicable everywhere wherever the data
is present even from mechanical
background you may go to the machines
you may go to the labs you have tons of
data which is related to your product
which is confidential and we should be
able to know how to protect that data
how to make it more secure what are the
ways in which we can be able to align
our mechanical background towards this
respective blockchain technology even
Niti ayog is also trying to transform so
many projects which are not from the IT
background still they are going ahead
and doing a lot of things so I would
suggest that you we will be having a
very good opportunity to know about this
technology and programming also it's
very simple and a new programming
language what we are going to learn is
new programming languages so you'll get
a very good chance to go ahead and learn
yourself and get a good exposure towards
technology it will be applicable to all
the domains to it and this is what we're
talking about in just a couple minutes
with regard to the IIT Concord program
yes yes
um Veronica asked a question if there's
there's a limitation on the number of
blocks that can be made
as of no no
sorry sweet as long as you have
computation power as long as you have
enough computation power you can go
ahead and mine as many blocks as you can
yeah and the chain can extend yes um as
far as you want it to extend absolutely
uh Suresh asks if the blockchain how how
does blockchain differ from the Big Data
distributed processing model where you
have uh Auto scaling of distributed nuts
for process
Big Data also has its own distributed
model right where you can be able to go
ahead and handle which I totally agree
with you Suresh blockchain is also
having the capability to distribute the
data but what they are having
additionally is like you can create a
decentralized application directly on
top of the blockchain and on top of that
you can also be able to use some
cryptographic algorithms on top of it
and can be able to make it much more
safe and secure and along with that you
can also be able to go ahead and create
your own